E aí
[Música]
e eu tenho certeza que todos aqui
presentes conhecem alguém ou já ouviram
pelo menos falar de alguém que possui
uma doença de pele que vive com esta
doença diariamente o aqui A dermatite
atópica psoríase e até o cancro de pele
são doenças que existem que estão
representadas em um terço da nossa
população mundial são dois. 5 mil
milhões de pessoas que apresentam estas
patologias e que vivem com elas
é claro que não todas mas algumas não
tem cura e portanto com incidência
crescente tem obviamente do impacto
físico e psicológico e contribuem para
uma diminuição Clara da qualidade de
vida destas pessoas
e portanto Quais são as soluções como é
que essas pessoas conseguem viver com
esta realidade
normalmente as pessoas que são seguidas
na clínica os tratamentos mais comuns
são a administração oral aplicação na
pele de anti inflamatórios O que é que
vão fazer vão aliviar os sintomas da
doença
Ok em alguns casos temos a questão de
surgirem infecções secundárias muito
resultado da utilização continuada
destes anti inflamatórios então além
deles temos que aplicar antibióticos com
a preocupação que todos conhecem que é
uma realidade atual do surgimento de
resistências nós temos ainda situações
mais graves em que a cirurgia é
inevitável que temos depois associado
sabiamente processos de recuperação
marcas que ficam para toda a vida e
Vocês perguntam Mas será que este é o
único cenário Será que não há outras
alternativas porque é que não optamos
por terapias não invasivas que realmente
existem terapias não invasivas uma delas
será a fototerapia que para quem não
conhece explico muito rapidamente será
uma técnica que Como o próprio nome diz
se baseia na utilização de luz na
incidência de luz neste caso em
particular na pele após a aplicação de
um farmaco portanto é aplicado um
fármaco no local da lesão no local onde
as células estão doentes e depois é
radiada uma luz idealmente uma luz na
zona do visível e isto quer dizer que se
na zona do visível Vai representar a
soma das cores do é importante o que não
vai ter qualquer efeito por si só
potente não vai ter toxicidade a luz em
Sim mas só quando incidida sobre Farma
que aplicamos Na pele é que vai ativá-lo
easyfarma que vai ter então o seu efeito
então perguntam vocês se a esse tipo de
tecnologia simples que não tem os
efeitos são as contraindicações que
acabamos referi no primeiro exemplo
Então por que não não só postarmos mais
porque não são porque é que não serão
estas
terapias mais vezes escritas a realidade
é que os fármacos aprovados até o
momento além de poucos não respondem à
diversidade de doenças de pele que
existem e portanto não são adequados
para todos apenas cerca de Metade dos
doentes dos pacientes seguidos na
clínica são recomendados para este tipo
de terapia e então este é o momento da
nossa conta é de que forma é que nós
conseguimos contribuir para este tipo de
terapia O que é que esta terapia precisa
de tão diferente que é que estes
fármacos tem que ter como eu vos disse a
terapia baseia-se na incidência de luz
luz na zona do visível e portanto estas
moléculas precisam de ter cor e onde é
que nós no nosso dia a dia vamos
encontrar moléculas com cor parece os
simples nós vamos cortar toda a nossa
volta mas na área da química alimentar
na área em que nós trabalhamos
diariamente as nossas fontes de
moléculas com cor são fontes naturais
são os frutos vermelhos são os vinho
tinto O Vinho do Porto alguns vegetais
aqui que nós vamos buscar as nossas
moléculas com cor e para que é que nos
servem estas moléculas com corpo que é
que temos tanto interesse nelas nós
tentamos perceber até que ponto é que
elas podem exercer um e para a nossa
saúde portanto Quais são as suas
propriedades benéficas para o ser humano
quando ingeridas oralmente e mais
recentemente começamos a pensar e por
que não aplicá-las diretamente na nossa
pele Será que isto funcionava até que
ponto é que poderiam estar associadas a
um retardar do investimento solar tanto
aquele envelhecimento que todos Queremos
que seja bastante lento
e mais ainda pensamos para além de
retardar o envelhecimento e as pessoas
que sofrem de Patologia Será que também
nessas não precisam de soluções e
portanto o tratamento de pele também era
um ponto importante e portanto dentro
das nossas diferentes Fontes moléculas
com corpo pensamos o vinho pode ser
ótimo Porque podemos ingeriu podemos
espalhar na pele e parece ser uma ótima
solução que é que se passa tinha uma
ótima desculpa para beber e spam e
eu imaginava que todos iriam gostar
muito desta solução mas a verdade é que
não passa por aí nós não queremos
promover o consumo de álcool e também
não queremos estragar vinho a espalhar o
Natal mas então se não vamos espalhar o
vinho da pele isso não vamos ver o pingo
de que forma é que Vinho do Porto nos
poderá ajudar a tratar doenças de pele o
vinho Muito provavelmente vocês já devem
ter bebido um copo de Vinho do Porto mas
no momento em que fazem esse ritual de
beber o copo de vinho não estão a
imaginar a quantidade de moléculas que
estão presentes nessa bebida e o próprio
antes de começar a trabalhar nesta área
não imaginava que existia uma grande
diversidade de moléculas e que tinham
ocorrido tantas transformações químicas
nesse vinho as moléculas que estão
presentes no vinho são os polifenóis e
além de estarem presentes no vinho estão
também presentes no outros alimentos que
nós consumimos todos os dias e os seus
benefícios para a saúde tem sido e ao
longo dos anos o nosso grupo de
investigação trabalha nessa área na área
da química do vinho e tem uma área
específica que trabalha com tentar
encontrar as moléculas que são
responsáveis pela alteração da cor do
vinho com o envelhecimento e se vocês já
olharam para um vinho do Porto Novo
vocês veem que tem uma cor muito intensa
e bastante vermelha e isso deve-se à
presença das antocianinas que são os
pigmentos que estão na uva mas também
são os pigmentos que estão nas flores
nos frutos vermelhos e em alguns legumes
e estes pigmentos estão novinho E além
disso o vinho Altera a sua cor para uma
tonalidade Mais Laranja durante o
envelhecimento isso acontece porque
porque esta esta Matriz vinho é muito
complexa devido aos componentes e todas
as moléculas que são extraídas durante o
processo de produção do vinho e além
disso as leveduras durante o processo de
fermentação que é conversão do açucar no
álcool também produzem moléculas essas
moléculas vão interagir todas umas com
as outras estão todas ali naquele
líquido e vão permitir com que formem
novas moléculas E essas novas moléculas
vão apresentar diferentes cores
essa no caso do vinho do porto devemos
ainda realçar que o vinho do Porto é um
vinho fortificado Ou seja que a
fermentação é parada pela Adição de uma
aguardente essa aguardente vai tornar
que que esta Matriz do Vinho do Porto
seja ainda mais com Ah e por isso as
transformações que podem ocorrer neste
tipo de vinho são muito superiores Isso
foi um desafio para nós estudar todas
essas vias de formação e todas as
moléculas que se podem formar neste tipo
de vinhos durante o envelhecimento
durante
o nosso trabalho o que é que nós
verificamos verificamos podemos
encontrar moléculas que tem uma cor
laranja tem uma cor vermelha uma cor
violeta e até uma cor azul claro que
vocês ficam a pensar mas então temos uma
cor azul novinho É verdade nós temos uma
cor azul só que a quantidade vezes
pigmentos novinho existem e muito
pequena concentração e por isso nós
nunca estaremos à espera de ter um copo
de 20 ser azul só que o nós percebemos
todas estas vias de transformação e toda
esta química esta complexidade ovinho
deu nos oportunidade de Nós criamos as
nossas moléculas e produzi-la sal o
laboratório ou seja se nós percebemos
como é que as moléculas são formadas
Novinho nós também podemos pegar nas
moléculas e produzi-las em laboratório e
portanto cinco visual ao produzi-los
sinteticamente e portanto foi o que nós
fizemos e que foi a nossa inspiração
para o nosso projeto mas para este
projeto em específico a fototerapia nós
dissemos que temos que usar uma luz
eclusa que nós temos que usar nós a iva
falou que temos que usar uma luz na zona
do visível mas idealmente nós devemos
usar uma luz vermelha porque é uma luz
de baixa intensidade que não é
que não nos faz mal à pele e além disso
tem a capacidade de penetração muito
maior nas camadas da pele e portanto irá
ser mais efetiva nesta fototerapia Mas
então ciência e luz vermelha é que nós
vamos usar que moléculas e qual a cor
que as nossas moléculas deverão ter as
nossas moléculas e acho que isto o que
deve ficar passar bem e que as pessoas
devem reter é que as moléculas devem ser
ou azuis ou verdes portanto nós temos
que produzir em laboratório moléculas
com diferentes estruturas que sejam
azuis ou verdes e essas moléculas depois
vão absorver a luz vermelha bom passar a
um estado ativado e depois vão
transferir essa energia para o oxigênio
que nos rodeia e depois essa molécula de
oxigênio ativada é que vai matar as
células doentes uma informação que
também é importante que vocês tenham
noção é que na fototerapia as nossas
moléculas Só se tem a sua ação de matar
as células quando ativadas pela luz ou
seja na ausência da Luz estas moléculas
Não tem qualquer toxicidade para o nosso
organismo isso é importante referir mas
studies dito desta forma parece que tudo
é muito fácil lhe parece que todas as
moléculas o ou azuis ou verdes poderão
ser utilizadas na fototerapia mas nós
sabemos que isso não é verdade é verdade
não é verdade que todas as azuis ou
verdes funcionam tivemos anos de
investigação nesta área e todas eram
azuis ou verdes mas na realidade Nem
todas eram ativadas por incidência de
luz e isso é importante é importante é
extremamente importante que as moléculas
que só sejam ativadas Pela Luz e no
escuro não tenham qualquer efeito e
porque é uma questão de seletividade nós
não queremos eliminar nem ter qualquer
toxicidade para as nossas células
saudáveis que por si só tem uma defesa
muito boa que todos vocês dorme acham
desejavam que ela se dividem de forma
lente daí que não o nosso processo de
envelhecimento não seja assim tão
acelerado enquanto que as células
doentes tem um processo de divisão
acelerado e portanto são as mais
afetadas por este sistema
um destes fármacos que um sistema One of
Isto é a luz em si ativos e eles têm a
capacidade de agir sobre as células
doentes e quando eliminamos a fonte de
luz eles rapidamente perdem assim feito
e como um efeito também é muito local
Eles não conseguem atuar a longas
distâncias quer dizer que só vão
exatamente exercer a sua ação naquele
local e então como é que nós estamos a
pensar aplicar este tipo de fármacos
sobre a pele sobre a forma de um vidro
Jam este hidrogel como vocês podem ver
vai ter então cores verdes cores azuis e
vai ser aplicado sobre a pele e depois
temos a necessidade de irradiar a nossa
pão
e eu acho que é importante também
referir a questão de como é que se faz o
tratamento vocês devem estar a pensar em
irradiar a pele Mas então eu vou
precisar de uma fonte de luz e realmente
quando nós aplicarmos esta Nossa solução
a nível de hospitais a nível de clínicas
por todo o mundo essa fonte de luz
existe porque já existem aparelhos
especializados que conseguem controlar a
intensidade que conseguem controlar a
duração do tratamento e que conseguem
atuar e fazer este tipo de terapia mas
não as gostávamos de ir mais longe nós
gostávamos de aplicar esta Nossa solução
em farmácias por todo mundo e tornaram
disponíveis a todos os presentes aos que
estão ouvir aos que querem ter um
tratamento mais acessível mas que não
tem possibilidades económicas ou que não
tem uma clínica disponível perto de casa
e portanto como é que nós vamos fazer
isso vocês devem estar a imaginar qual é
a fonte de luz que eu tenho que é
gratuita quer a todos que nasce todos os
dias é simples Senai Portanto o sol o
sol realmente vai ser a nossa fonte de
luz vermelha porque o meu vos disse nas
cores do arco-íris nós temos lá o
vermelho e então será que eu posso
aplicar o meu hidrogel e será que eu
posso ir para a praia fazer a minha foto
a terapia Óbvio que não certo porque uma
exposição prolongada e desprotegida ao
sol vai me criar outro tipo de problemas
portanto como é que tem que ser esta
exposição esta exposição tem que ser em
casa aplicam o vosso hidrogel e
calmamente relaxam alguns minutos e
recebem a luz solar através de uma
janela enquanto apreciam um bom copo de
vinho enquanto acabam os últimos
capítulos do vosso livro e assim é
encontrada a solução ideal é não sei
coração do Sucesso juntar as moléculas
de Vinho do Porto com a luz solar e
temos um tratamento acessível para todos
E aí
[Música]